let's try um why don't we go to sam
from princeton massachusetts not
princeton new jersey
hey david do you hear me yes i can um
so i'll preface this by saying i i sort
of realized that this isn't exactly the
top of like priorities right now
okay but i was just on twitter before i
came in this lobby and i'm seeing
there's lawmakers in some sort of
congressional meeting and i've seen it
going on a little bit i'm talking about
trans people
in athletics and sort of legislating
that
process now i'm on the left
i consider myself to be ardently pro
trans rights and everything but it does
at the same time seem pretty deeply
unfair to me that
to allow you know people who are born
biologically different to for example
trans women to participate in men's
sports right in women's sports
i mean listen it sounds like we have the
same view i've talked about this before
which is
i have a problem with people that
pretend like this is the big issue the
big injustice that's going on and it
sounds like you're saying the same thing
you recognize this is not like the
biggest issue at the same time when i
think about a sport like weightlifting
or wrestling and i think about someone
born biologically male
and then saying well they now um
they they identify as uh as a woman
and they're going to participate in
wrestling or weightlifting
it strikes me as not making complete and
total sense and this does not in any way
affect the fact that i believe uh trans
folks should be able to live lives
free of discrimination uh they should be
included in uh protections when it comes
to employment
and uh should be able to have a license
that reflects their
uh uh gender as as they want to exist in
the world
and yet it just doesn't i just don't
understand how you say
well someone born biologically male can
participate in women's wrestling it
i don't i don't get it i get that you're
not uh saying it's the most important
issue neither am i
it's not even the most important issue
within trans
rights to me there are so many more
important issues within trans rights
but yeah i'm basically with you i would
love somebody to explain it to me
yeah i totally and the thing that i that
sort of concerns me is like
because i i watch your show and i watch
other things too and
what the sense that i get is that um i
would be called a transphobe for that
and i'm you know i'm seeing people like
in the majority report and that sort of
thing
saying you know that opinion people are
sort of dunking on like tulsi gabbard
for having that opinion saying she's not
really on the left and i was thinking
well i mean i don't know if that's fair
you know
well here's the thing i mean the the
question is
so i i've said before how
you can be in favor of the movement to
boycott
israeli products and services without
being anti-semitic
but it also is a great cover for lots of
anti-semitic folks
much the same way you can have this
position or these questions
about uh the the the trans women's
sports issues
and be using it as a cover for your
transphobia
or not you might be a staunch defender
of trans rights and anti-trans
discrimination and still have that
question so it's not a rule that that
you are
or are not transphobic because you are
trying to better understand this issue
as i am
right yeah that's where i see myself so
yeah anyway thanks for
taking my call all right my pleasure
appreciate the call very very much
that is all the time we have for today i
apologize i was not able to get to
everybody
but i hope to be able to at some point
in the future